this from Holly math nerd why is
transgender identity even without
transition celebrated but transracial
identity is considered an appalling
appropriation of oppression not your own
Thank You Holly
that's a great question well and in fact
we I've now forgotten the woman's names
it's different we had it we had an
academic famously canceled over making
exactly so somebody made this argument
in an academic paper I mean you know
didn't make the argument pro or con but
basically said is this analogous and a
firestorm erupted so let's put it this
way the reason that we don't notice that
inconsistency is because we have
completely given up on the idea of
consistent yeah assistance he has a
virtue people love us back yes our
people wolf is back now wagging carry a
large donut around a flange here yeah
it's it's totally incoherent
inconsistent and it reveals the
hypocrisy of the of the field the
scholarship and if you could point that
out to an individual it reveals maybe
not the hypocrisy but if they don't
think on it and get back to you and say
I see that I have to accept both of
these are neither of these as in order
to remain consistent then it suggests
very strongly that they are not working
from first principles but working from
received wisdom yep and if you can just
do a thought experiment here to it's
possible no no no okay well try not to
get us in too much hot water but it is
possible that a person could transition
from white to black so long as they took
up and aggressively I don't want to say
Pro black so I don't think this movement
is Pro black but an officially
sanctioned Pro black position but if you
were to imagine somebody transitioning
Jean King style to black and taking up a
skeptical position of the movement it
not function which tells you something
about where we are that what is
permitted is no longer about logic at
all
it's about what you plan to do having
done so and anyway that's not how logic
works right you will be required to
adopt these ideas if and only if you
also agree with this over here otherwise
you are prohibited from doing so
[Music]